*piano music*
WHAT THE FUCK DI-
[urging to puke]
Yep..
TAY SWAY
Guide me
*inaudible*
♪ Taylor Swift - Blank Space ♪
Choo Choo on this
mother fucker.
♪ Taylor Swift - Blank Space ♪
Yep..
What the fuck are they doing???
WHY?!
[VICTORY SCREAM]
Yep..
[Groaning]
*Poods is grossed out*
You wanna see some fireworks m8? (nu)
[lighter clicks]
Not everyone is ready...
[Groaning]
*More fart like groaning*
Yeah you better back up a little bit more man..
♪ Intense Dubstep ♪
[groaning]
*More Fart Groans -3-*
[burp]
No fear!
Thats right!
[jumpscare]
Okay- you're good
You're good
Thank you.
Yep..
[vomits]
Oh, its good!
[puking intensifies]
(Background: I hate peedeepie)
Because... pewdiepie
sucks and..
his fans
sucks.
Fanboys...
Pewdiepie sucks...
I hate fucking pewdiepie...
Don't call me fat..
because your fat too!
BITCH!
*Silence*
*Poods contemplating life decision*
Yep..*oh fuck*
Here we go...
OH
OHH
OHHH
OHHHH
AHH
AHHHH
BROS!
I'll have you know I LOVE YOU
❤ I will never forget you ❤
♪ Dramatic Music ♪
This is it.
Hey! Im actually fine :D
[explosion]
This one's for TImmy!
This is it for Private Clutch
Sorry, I don't think I'm gonna make it!
I'm out of ammo!
Tell my subs..
Tell the Bros..
[radio]: Private Pie, I've got good news!
- What?
[radio]: You've taken out the enemy
They're all dead!
- Really?
Oh..
Well, how about that bitches!
Yep..
[woman]: I think PewDiePie probably does prank videos
like, with dick slaps, I don't know..
*deadpanned face*
*I am disappointed.*
[Pewds: Surprise motherfucker!
Surprise motherfucker!!
Oh! OH MY GOD!
NO! NO! NUN
HUN HUN HUH AH
PFF PFSS PFFU
*BOOM BITCH*
Oh! WHAT THE SHT WAS THAT-
Zero deaths!
Pewds never dies!
What is this magical device?
[laughs]
[laughing continues]
OH! OH! OH! OH! OH
OH! OH! OH! OH! OHHHH!
Haters doubted that I couldn't do it..
But they were-
*rlly bitch?*
This is art!
Like, this-is-art!
You can't argue with art!
Hey!!
♪ Inspirational Music ♪
*I'm VERY uncomfortable right nao.*
♪ KSI - Lamborghini (Ear Rape) ♪
[guy in the phone]: Hello..
[Pewds]: I will find you..
- Hum, why??
- I will look for you!
- What the fuck
- And I will fist you- ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Brofist.. you! *shit! nvm*
- Are you crazy?
- No..
I'm pewdiepie...
- Ehmm, okay..
*Call Ends*
[laughs]
Man..
Literally felling this..
I'm in another game.
Oh my God
There's a car level coming up!
*pewds tries a daring attempt to get sum pussy.*
How you ladies doing?
MORE!
MOORE!
YEAHH!
Ahh
Taste good!!
YEAHH!
OHHH
MORE!
MORE POW-
♪ ROCK ♪
ZERO DEATHS.
It's a tricky part
[Conan]: Are you nervous about playing with me humm, you know legend
- I think you should be nervous
- Yeah?
- I've seen you play Conan
[laughs]
- You're pretty awful! I-
[Pewds]: We can't make any more mistakes!
[Cry]: Cut......the.....
[Cry]: Alright, you said there's a red wire?
- No!
FU--*dies before explodes*
What does it say?
It's the 1 million one
and it's fucking BROKEN!
"Congrats for surpassing one million!"
Oh that's cool!
That happened years ago!
GIVE ME 44 OF THESE!! (55*)
Hey Jack!
This is what your fans think you look like..*Helloooo...*
but this is what you really look like! *ohhhhhhh*
Which is convinient..
because you videos are about as cringey
as a dove commercial!
[some kid]: I can't fuckng stand you, you son of a bitch!
[Pewds]: I think this guy is actually legit!
- You're a fucking useless YouTuber you little cunt!
- Oh, oh, heyy
No!
- You make thousands of dollars..EVEN MILLIONS OF DOLLA--
- [laughs]
Thousands of dollars..
That's cute!
[laughs]
I'm gonna shave!
[Maya]: Fine...
If you shave..
I'll make it so that Marzia..
Won't!
*OH FUCK*
♪ Swaggy Music ♪
They call me Beast Master 64!
I'm the greatest pokeman hunter alive.
♪ Dramatic Music ♪
Step by step..
OUGHH *JUMPSCARES*
*c'mere bitch*
*distorted* Game Over..
The fuck was that?
That's a Pokémon right there!
That's a Pokémon!
OH MY GOD ;-;
That's my Pokémon!
*GUNSHOT*
♪ Dramatic Music ♪
♪ Emotional Music ♪
If Pokémon aren't real
Then dogs aren't real either
*SOBBINGS*
*GUNSHOT*
[SCREAMS]
FUUUUUUU-
"I can't believe this happened.."
"I can't believe this.."
"You won't believe this.."
"SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE ME!!" *fucking liar*
" I CAN'T BELIEVE THESE KIDS.." *they smoke crack?*
"CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS.."
" I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.."
" I CAN'T BELIEVE I FELL!!"
" I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.."
" I CAN'T BELIEVE I FOUND THIS.."
" CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS?"
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT!!
HE CAN'T BELIEVE IT!!
YOU WON'T BELIEVE THIS
Get the boat!
Get the boat! Get-
The Pok-A-Bitch!
I'm gonna have to send a Pok-A-Bitch
C'mon Pok-A-Bitch!
GO POK-A-BITCH!
AHH!
C'mon! OH!
GET HER!!!!
Don't film this!
[Sorshit]: What the fuck are you doing?
- Yeah what the fuck am I doing?
- What the fuck are you doing?
- Godammit! What the fuck am I doing?
What the fuck am I DOING?
- What the fuck are you doing?
- I'm not a vegan!
I wasn't dead! Oh my God!
NO!!
♪ 'Cause you had a bad day ♪
♪ Your takin one down ♪
[Pewdiepie]: Just sing a sad song, just turn it around..
If you don't have core message as making a positive
impact on the planet, what the-
W-w-w-w-w-what t-t-the
What the fuck are you doing?
- Oh my God there it is!
- There it is!
There it is! It's right there!
Remember me!
Camera man.. Remember me!
So, Sky News posted:
"Popular YouTuber PewDiePie unverified due to suspected relations with ISIS.."
It seems legit right?
We got it!!
Yes!
[laughs]
Where's the drone seriously? OK
The fuck was that sound?
*SIGN MY SHIRT BITCH!*
AHHHHHH!
[Malcom]: The most important part..
- The most important part, here it comes.. ok
- PewDiPie is gay!
Pewdiepie EXPOSED
[Marzia]: You can even scoop your tongue
like that and you hold it and then you just-
- I see..
There's a Demon on-
[Marzia screams]
How does that EXISSS-
I will send out my greatest
achievement.. Squirtle!
I've infuse him with my own DNA
FIRE THE CANONS!
♪ Dramatic Music ♪
*Cannons Bursting*
Squirtle..
♪ Dramatic Music ♪
I need to save him!
Sending the helicopter!
♪ Dramatic Music ♪
♪ Sad Music ♪
My face is just like:
"Oh God, this is gonna be in the internet forever now.."
OH!
Aw shit!
Oh no!
Yep..
To get your core message across
you really gotta hit those points.. fast!
Marina get it fast!
As much information as fucking POSSIBLE!
GO!
[Marina Joyce]: You should watch, 'Cow Spiracy??'
because it's a very good thing to watch,
but it's gorey, so I don't recommend watching it.
What the fuck does that mean? Ouch! Shit.
[Minacha]: I'm minacha please..
- "I'm minacha please.."
Minacha please...
You're a minacha please?
Minacha please
*best dance ever*
...
Please satan..
No... No more...
dancing. *do my evil bidding*
UGH!
Nein..Nein.. ;-;
AAAAH *screams*
Oh no you saw me!
Oh.. ohh.. T_T
That's so embarassing
You sold everything what do you have now?
I have....
*laughs*
I have bullet ball.
*cries*
I don't even have a home to go back to...
♪ Inspirational Music ♪
You don't understand.
I'm gonna pleasure myself with this fish.
It is- pleasure yourself!
What the fuck!
Fuck this game!
What the fuck me? You recommended the game!
You recommend--
*relationship goals af*
♪ Romantic Music ♪
*surprised*
*laughter*
*He done fucked up*
Pewds: Oh, wow...what is it?? Wehfhehuh...you think because you have green hair, you're better than me?
Jack: I didn't turn off the comments.
*waht*
GET PIED
Marzia??: You want me to take it off?
Pewds: Not now...we're filming...
*...*
*FUCK.*
*laughs*
*ZZZZZZZAP!!* Jack: OOOOOH!!!
Pewds: *laughs* Jack: I felt that here and here!!
Jack: That was weir--No!! GO AWAY you fucking...asshole..
Marzia??: Keep your eyes open and look at me when you kiss me.
*fangirls....no.NO.*
♪ To the sky ♪
♪ To the moon ♪
♪  Making my Skyline brand new ♪
[Guy #1]: ...work if we get 50K likes, so...you don't need to hit it or anything, but..uh...FUCKING hit it.
Pewdiepie: AYO WHAT IS UP!!! 50 MILLION LIKES!! CAN WE HIT IT UP ON THIS VIDEO?!?!
50 MILLION!!! SMASH THAT LIKE BUTTON!!! IT'S RIGHT DOWN THERE I KNOW YOU SEEN IT!!!
WHAT ARE YOU? BLIND??! *no i'm frank.*
*Pewdiepie.exe has stopped working.*
[Michael]: Don't eat anymore! You're crazy! I put a whole...pipette....of this.....CRAZY stuff in it.
[Pewds]: You actually did it?
[Pewds]: Michael. For real? [Michael]: Yeah...
*EEEEEEEEENGH*
You know...part of me is angry...but the other part is real proud that you tried to kill me.
I'm poppy
I swear to you...at 50 million subs...when we hit 50 million....I am deleting my channel.
*drowning in sorrow*
*eeew...that's gnarly*
I wanna die. *same*
Poppy: I can't find it...*find what?*
I think she's looking for her-
she's looking for her quality content.
♪ Why cant we be friends ♪
Jack: Technically, now at..1.3 Million dollars.
*Screams of Joy*
*OHHHHHHHHHH*
[Edgar]: NEXT ingredient.
Edgar: Every Christmas...was a sad memory...because grandma was an alcoholic.
Edgar: But we have to honor.....her recipe.
dun do it
oh noes
ONE MILLLION DISLIKES!! OR I'LL DROWN MYSELF.
*screams of pain*
AHAHAHHAHAHAHAHAHHA
That was the joke.
That was it...that was...the.........that was the joke.
First of all....WE did this. Oh! It's got the brofist!
It's a custom!
That's really fucking cool.
AN exclusive...ULTRA rare...it smells LOVELY.
Alright! I hope you enjoyed this montage.
And if ya did... make sure you leave aaa.....
Actually...why don't you check out ANOTHER montage..that we did last year?
I think 2016, was one of my favorite years on YouTube so far...aaaand...it would not be possible...without you guys watching.
Subscribing, Balling...(wait wut) ...and all that shit. So, I appreciate that...and thank you. It means the world me.
'Fo you click...bwoOwfist.